hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we're
gonna go down into the ocean we're gonna
go deep we're gonna go way down there
and we're gonna try to find the big Ozzy
the ben Guzzi the boo boo boo shabi the
bible though the boo baby did whatever
they're called I can't even walk and I
never remember that name I'm the worst
with names but either way we're gonna go
down there we're gonna find this place
and we're gonna find their information
about what is down deep in the inactive
lava zone and maybe find some cool stuff
on the way so let's get to it
hear ye hear ye denizens of the deep
Marc EMU is coming the [ __ ] down oh boy
that don't look good
Hamm bunk hello anybody home
anybody anybody home anybody want a
tussle with the muscle huh no alright
then you probably chose wisely okay
where am i where am i exactly oh okay I
might have found the entrance to the
lava zone or something this goes down D
okay it's awfully terrifying in here
well alright then that's weird is that
the C Treader I hope so detecting a
titanium mass somewhere in this area
unable to confirm whether it originated
in the Aurora Oh are we talking about we
talking about the other base oh I think
we're talking about the other base here
is the other base down here I mean it
would be the weirdos they always do like
to settle in the weirdest places so
somewhere in here there's a base on
there's a thermal vent well that's
awfully handy Dana why didn't I build my
base down here oh because my C mouth
can't get down this far well [ __ ] me
then there's a titanium mass somewhere
in here he needs some titanium a Jessie
- gah see the DES Gossie that's what it
was the DES Gossie oh my god what the
[ __ ] is that
Hey
[Music]
okay all right okay just go get the [ __ ]
out of here
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I'm just gonna go
farther down don't mind me going down
baby what the [ __ ] Rio that's a war / oh
that is a war / oh I shouldn't be here
oh this is bad me oh god why am I going
farther down this bad I'm gonna lose my
goddamn prawn [ __ ] okay do I go farther
oh that's not good that's not that's
that's not whatever that was that's not
good oh I am an oh my god that is
terrible what is that oh my god hey this
I gotta go oh yeah oh yeah yeah yo I
didn't want to go down this way but I
didn't have a choice I was being pressed
in from all sides war person whatever
the [ __ ] that other thing was Jesus
where is this leading oh jesus found the
way down
oh I'm not happy about it not happy
about it
oh not happy about this oh not happy
about this what the [ __ ] is this what
the [ __ ] is it's a lost river okay music
yeah you just cut out you don't need to
keep playing yeah I think I'm pretty
sure this might be the Lost River didn't
mean to find this oh boy oh boy oh boy
alright
oh god I don't want to go down yet am I
ready the problem is I'm not ready to go
down I have no food oh god what is that
that tail of something or is that it
there's just a loading thing I hate to
be that guy but I'm not ready to go down
there
I'm just not if I go down there I'm
gonna die and I'm gonna lose my prong
suit I'm literally I'm low health low
food low water I'm just not ready oh if
I go down there I'll die I have to be
smart about this I have to find out
where how to get out of here and where
the [ __ ] does this lead what is this
[ __ ]
what is this is this anything now it's
nothing's like a goof it's a goof yeah
it's just a it's just a [ __ ] goof oh
boy I gotta get out of here I hate to be
that guy but I just I'm not ready I'll
die there's no food down there there's
no water that's drinkable uh yah yah yah
yah yah yah e
okay so as I make my cowardly return
back to my base I was looking for
titanium and I did not find it I found
death a lot of that excess amounts of
death and horror I am gonna read the
comments that I was gonna put on Locker
but I ran out of titanium to make those
I will put them on Locker it says I
won't be able to do it today once I get
the titanium and I god I got to get out
of here live okay so pretty much
everyone in the comments section said
that the ghost Leviathan is a thing the
ghost Leviathan is actually going to be
a thing
what the [ __ ] is that okay bad bad bad
so what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
be locker and put everyone on it
literally the word everyone to all of
you will be on the locker oh god no no
[ __ ] you oh [ __ ] where am I
how could you oh god [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
dude [ __ ] you dude [ __ ] you dude oh no
where's my where where is it where's it
there it is oh my god don't do that I'm
low on health oh my god getting out here
oh [ __ ] okay next up Sean marks 35 uh
who suggested I don't get the water
purifier until I get sandy source of
power
Oh God uh hey I got turned around it in
I didn't mean to go this way I'll trying
to go a different way Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
where's my goddamn bass it's up there
okay it's got to go over there just
gonna make it gotta make it gonna make
it okay so I won't do that I'll I'll
take my time with that and then pass the
word 35 set when you completely remove
pool powers and problems as always and
invest in reinforcements hey [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] fo [ __ ] this fits infested
oh god there's so many of them oh I'm in
the middle of the death oh god [ __ ] off
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh yeah I hate this I hate
this goddamn go [ __ ] go I'm gonna
side step out of here get the [ __ ] out
there [ __ ] go is that titanium I
figure that might be titanium guys I
think I found some guys good Dios what
was that looking where to go
oh no lad [ __ ] [ __ ] off okay what's
that it's at a wreck oh it is
it's our wreckage down here whoa I
didn't know that holy [ __ ] and see what
this is
scanner room oh hell yeah I'll take that
[ __ ] yeah emergency severe dehydration
I know I know I know I know I know I
know I know I'm gonna grab a couple of
these
well [ __ ] kill that it's dead it's very
dead
that's a dead one okay dead bladder fish
is okay so I gotta find I got to do this
quickly because I'm gonna get this
because I don't I'm not sure I'm gonna
find this again I'll go in this one when
I come back to it I thought I scanned
this alien containment fragment alien
containment fragment the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
is that
I don't want to contain alien I want I
want to kill them all
geez that I want to contain him okay so
the unfortunate thing is I think I have
to go in there to get the rest of the
pieces unless there's some pieces down
this trench here which it looks like
there is I don't know what it's two but
either way it's gonna give me what I
need scanner room okay so I'm gonna go
back in there when I find this again cuz
I'll find it again I should be able to
find it again but I gotta get back
because I'm about to die a thirst if I
die I'm this is all for nothing I got to
get back in there like immediately
oh why did I cut this so close I don't
know cuz I'm an idiot
that's why oh I have [ __ ] I've [ __ ]
myself over haven't I oh I'm cutting
goddamn this weapon this episode is just
[ __ ] nuts
okay and it did it did it that day
hey holy [ __ ] no you're not the one I
need oh cheese please go faster Oh God
okay come on come on come on come on get
the water in you get the water in you
get the water in you I did I have water
on me I have no idea get the food not
the bladder fish goddamn it that's not
what I wanted to do whatever done matter
okay good good good good good yes okay
good god this holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this
entire episode man there's been nuts
there's been a bonkers bonkers episode
okay all right I need titanium I need a
lot of titanium I need odors god I know
I mean I'm in a bad way but what I do
and don't have is everything and what I
do and don't want is everything so I am
I'm in I'm in a spot of bother here but
before I do that I'm gonna put I'm gonna
put my seamoth in the docking bay just
do cuz I feel I feel like I've left
I've left my seamoth out of here and
just taken mr. Pfister for granted when
in fact I want it to be the other way
around I love God dear why I just
[ __ ] really are you gonna mr. Pfister
is it because you think I'm about to
neglect you well no that's not true I
just don't like you all right you're
just not as good as bubble what sorry to
say bubble but had a drill arm I'd be a
lot happier in my life
thanks Karen you are a doll aren't you
okay so that's gonna power that up how
Biscay barely any power you just sip
power baby you're so good and I'm gonna
color you up bubble bud whoop
nope yeah wait gotta see whatever doing
here oh no what if we make it a bumble
bee Oh what if we make it a bumble bee
oh oh that's so nice
oh this lovely oh I would have called
you bumble but oh oh it's bumble boy
oh so cute Oh ugly on inside but oh it's
so cute Oh bumble but I love you oh
that's so good okay so what can I do
probably nothing that is the seamoth
perimeter defense system which would be
awfully nice polyaniline I don't how to
make that
do I know how to make that what is
polyaniline I have no idea what that is
I have no idea so I've got a lot on my
plate I've got a few more things before
I want to end this episode but I got a
lot on my plate the first thing I need
to do above all else is as usual go get
[ __ ] titanium and go take care of my
goddamn dehydration [ __ ]
yeah I know I've got a plan I've got
something over here I can take care of
this I also think I might be able to
make I might be able to make that water
filtration system now it would suck a
lot of power out of what I got but at
the same time I might be able to afford
a little bit of a little bit of excess
here because it would stop oh but it
costs two titanium [ __ ] alright so I
gotta do that uh [ __ ] okay so
everything is what the [ __ ] was that did
you hear that that was the weirdest
sound I've ever heard what the [ __ ] was
that I don't know and I don't want to
know and I I don't know anything yet I'm
gonna save ya anyway so what I need to
do now is I need to go get titanium and
oh my god bumble but I love you so much
you're so much better than the prawn
suit in every way you are better than
the prawn suit God you are just so
nimble you're so gloriously nimble oh I
love you [ __ ] I love you baby
whoa oh that's have I seen that have I
seen this one I don't know if I have I
think I would have recognized a piece
like this just jetting straight up out
of the middle of this sanded area I
think I've ever seen this one before
what do you have Oh
alien containment fragment well you got
the other piece of that that I needed so
that's good I think you still get some
titanium out of this one but maybe I can
get some answers out of this one too I
mean eventually I'll need some water
damage to plan life on the seafloor
suggests this may be the migration path
of Hugh
bottom-dwelling life-form
Oh
well okay that was that was those
disturbingly loud and I'm not sure why
that happened but I'm gonna go in here
it's kind of you know explore a bit well
this looks damaged heavily damaged I'm
just gonna get the titanium out of these
alien containment fragments because what
what the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ] was
that okay weird okay
nuclear yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes oh that's good oh that is good okay
I need to unwell this oh no five time
for this gonna get a little bit cut cut
cut cut cut cut cut cut cut cut cut cut
cut cut cut cut cut cut okay guy half
done job there but yes nuclear reactor
means so much nuclear reactor means all
of my power problems are gone it takes a
lot to build the nuclear reactor that I
know from the last time that I tried to
build one
I had to cheat to do it and even through
cheating I had to like it was so hard I
had to press so many buttons on the
console it was so difficult but that
should be good and that should do me so
well in the future yes yes oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] on supra OH
oh my god this this particular wreck is
awesome also I'm hearing very disturbing
sounds and I have bad feelings about
that oh that's awesome
the propulsion arm would be crazy oh
hell yeah
this particular wreck is the best wreck
that I've ever found I just need one
more nuclear reactor piece cuz it's got
to be in here right [ __ ] Oh running out
of oxygen like right now okay sue this
but there's gotta be there's got to be
another piece around here if it's not in
there there might be another entrance
somewhere
could be whoa what the [ __ ] I'm here cuz
I [ __ ] god damnit [ __ ] off Nana
nanana Nana I'm out of here baby I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out eh [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off what are you doing where do
you go
oh he teleported I'm gonna assume he's
teleporting to Mei [ __ ] [ __ ] off with
you you piece of [ __ ]
goddammit ah I don't want to leave
without the nuclear reactor fragment
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy
Jesus okay so I thought I saw another
entrance in here but I just [ __ ] I can't
take many more of those hits gonna die
Jesus Christ
why is he off he's like following me
around where did he go oh [ __ ] there you
go
no no no no you stay away stay away okay
so maybe there was another entrance up
top nothing ah [ __ ] I gotta go get water
where is this place in relation to
everything this is way off the beaten
path this is like way way way off the
beaten path goddamn it and the only
entrance was over there wasn't it
there's just one more piece that I need
[ __ ] he just pops in and out there I'm
gonna go for it and I go for it slide in
slide it into those DMS oh [ __ ] where am
I
oh god no I slid too hard slid too hard
into the DMS oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no no no no Bubble Boy help go get help
on my back go get help
ba ba ba ba ba bum BA bum bumble don't
let me die this way ba ba ba ba do you
hear me bumble but do you hear me bumbly
ba BOM ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
[ __ ] I'm dead well all I can hope is
that the warper will warm me out of here
to safety
Wooper help hey babe oh [ __ ] god dammit
god dammit god dammit oh it's
right there let me out [ __ ] I'm in oh
[ __ ] man at least I know where that
wreck is now Oh No okay
that's gonna do it for this episode this
episode has been a nightmare but a
progress making nightmare
so I found the pieces to the nuclear
reactor I know where the wreck is
there's a warper that's on my ass but I
think I can make it okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching I promise
I'm gonna make those goddamn lockers but
so thanks again as always I will see you
in the next video bye
[Music]